here's a report this is from a website
called the main wire mainwire.com
um Maine is in the state of Maine a
public school worker at Great Salt Bay
Community School who coached a 13 year
old girl into a gender transition
without telling her parents
has only a conditional license to
practice social work in Maine the main
wire has learned Amber Levine the mother
of the young girl revealed at a school
board meeting on Wednesday that she
discovered a chest binder in her
daughter's bedroom several weeks ago her
daughter told her that the binder was
provided by a social worker at the
public school who encouraged her to keep
it secret from her parents
that's when Levine learned that the
social worker and other school staff had
started a social gender transition for
the girl in October without her parents
knowledge or consent sources have
confirmed the social worker in question
is Sam Roy a 26 year old University of
Maine graduate student who has a
conditional license from the state of
Maine to work as a social worker Roy
started started working with the
damariscada school this fall Roy is
scheduled to graduate next year from the
University of Maine with his master's
degree in social work
so he doesn't even have to have the
degree yet but he has taken charge of
this girl's quote unquote social
transition
um Levine learned that the school had
begun transitioning her daughter when
she discovered a chest binder in the
girl's bedroom chest binder is a device
that flattens the appearance of a
woman's breasts they're sometimes used
by individuals suffering from gender
dysphoria or gender confusion unless one
properly binders can cause or exacerbate
health problems
um binders are typically used during
social gender Transitions and are
considered a stepping stone to an
eventual double mastectomy of course
surgery that removes healthy breath
breast tissue
although Levine knew that her daughter
was seeing a social worker through the
school she did not know that her
daughter was reassigned to rule in
October she has never seen or talked to
Roy okay
so this is and this is uh
not as unusual as we want to think it is
this is certainly not unprecedented
where a school is
it's it's not even just that the school
knows
that a child identifies as the other
gender and is not telling the kid the
parent about it that's bad enough that's
already horrific
uh for the school I mean schools should
not
a school should not know anything about
your child that you do not know
there should be no information at all
none that the school knows about your
kid that you don't know
because when we talk about the school
the school is not some sort of amorphous
uh entity it's we're talking about
people
and so is there any individual person
who works at the school who has a right
to know information about your child
that you don't
obviously not
and that is especially the case when it
comes to something like this so that's
bad enough if they're just concealing
just I mean if they're concealing this
kind of information but in this case
they are actually
facilitating this quote-unquote
transition themselves
took it upon themselves to do that
of course while not only not telling the
parents but actively concealing it from
them
by the way this article says that uh I I
want to make sure to note this the
article says
that chest binders unless worn properly
can are damaging well that's that's
there is no proper way to wear them they
are damaging period
the the whole point is to flatten you
know
um the chest it's there's there's no
healthy or proper way to do that there
are ways that are
you know so when we talk about proper or
healthy way of wearing a chest binder
what they really mean to say are here's
the way to do it that will supposedly
mitigate some of the harm that this is
going to cause the child but there still
will be harm no matter how you slice it
um and this is all this is one step
towards the towards the surgery
so when the left says
they're not they're not performing these
surgeries on kids that's a lie first of
all they are performing surgeries on
kids they're performing double
mastectomies on girls as young as 15 14
years old maybe even younger
but also the the so-called social
transition
that is about putting the child on the
conveyor belt
which leads directly to the surgery
and most of the kids will stay on that
conveyor belt
all the way down you know until they get
to the part where with with the saws and
the blades
that's what it's about
um
and the schools they don't see any
problem with this
because as far as they're concerned
it these kids are theirs the kids belong
to them
and you should know that so I'm always
preaching about homeschool
but if you can't do homeschool and you
feel like you have to send your kid to
public school it really should be the
last resort but if you're going to do it
then you should you should just
understand that you cannot you cannot
implicitly trust anyone there
you especially can't trust counselors
therapists social workers
I mean you can't we're at a point now
sad to say
where you can't trust people in that
field at all
I mean that entire field is
ideologically captured it is hostile to
you and uh it just is you cannot trust
it
I would not send my kid to any of these
people period especially not unattended
so if your kid does you know if you
really feel like your kid needs to see
some sort of counselor then you need to
be in the room
but the schools this is what they
believe that they they own your kids the
kids belong to them you are um
talk about things being inverted you
know you are you're the the hot you are
basically the hired help and they
have ownership of your child that's how
they see it
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]